ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนน้องก็
กลับมาเจอกับเรา 2 คนหญิงครูป๊านะคะใน
วีดีโอระดับบีกินเนอร์
ก้อย
วันเนาะใช่วันนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้าวันนี้
วันอังคารไหมค่ะวันนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 7  5
เดือนอะไร
เดือนธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่
เท่าไหร่คะเดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่ 12
ค่ะ
ดีพ.ต.ท
เมื่อปีพศ
2564 ค่ะปีคศราคาปีคศ 2  021 ค่ะเช้า
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไร
เมื่อวานนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะวันจันทร์ที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันจันทร์ที่ 6 ค่ะเดือน
เดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็น
เดือนที่ 12 ค่ะปีพต
2564 ปีคศ 2  021 หากพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันพุธค่ะวันพุธที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
พุธที่ 8 ค่ะเดือนเดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็นเดือนที่
ข้อ 2 ค่ะตีผชมีผช
2564  a  Call ศ.
2021 ค่ะหนึ่ง
ก็วันนี้วันอังคารแล้วแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่
โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา 11 โมง 12
นาทีค่ะอ๋อ
11:00 น
12 นาที
11 โมงแล้ว
ครูฟ้ากับครูหญิงน่ะก็ตื่นแล้วนะวะ
11:00 นแล้วรูซ้ากินข้าวเช้าหรือยังคะ
ว่าตอนนี้ 11 โมงแล้วใช่ไหมคะชั่วโมงหน้า
เป็นตอนเที่ยง
สมัยตอนเที่ยงเนี่ยก็จะเป็นข้าวแต่ว่านี่
เรื่องฟ้าผู้หญิงยังไม่ได้กินแต่ตอนเช้า
อาจจะ
8:00 น 8:00 นหรือว่า 7:00 น
ตอนเช้าเนาะรู้ฟ้ากินอาหารเช้าเรื่องคะ
ตอนเช้านะคะครูฟ้ากินอาหารเช้าแล้วค่ะโล้
กินกี่โมง
กินอาหารเช้า 8 โมงค่ะตอบ 8 โมงตรงเลยใช่
ไหมคะค่ะ 8 โมงตรงค่ะแล้วก็ฟ้ากินอาหาร
เช้ากินอะไร
กินกินข้าวเหนียวหมูปิ้งหักเขาเดี๋ยวไม่
ได้งงแล้วเนี่ยอะไร
เหนียว
โพนี่ครูฟ้ากินข้าวเหนียว
เอาหมูปิ้ง
งู
ในโลกนี้มีข้าวเหนียว 1 ห่อมีหมูปิ้ง
1233 ไม้ไม่ช้าหน่ะกินข้าวเหนียวหมูปิ้ง
ตอนเช้าใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้ากินข้าวเหนียวกี่
ห่อ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยครูฟ้ากินข้าวเหนียว 2 ห่อ
แล้วหมูปิ้งกี่ไม้หมูปิ้ง 8 ไม้หาด
เพราะว่ามีปิ๊กภัยมันเล็กๆไม่ใช่ๆๆๆตอน
นี้เรียน
ให้นักเรียนดูหมูปิ้งแหละ
มันเล็กๆนะกินอ่ะ
1 ไม้ไม่โอเคไม่พอ
สองไม่พอ
3 ไม่บอกครูฟ้าก็เลยกินเอาหมูปิ้ง
ข้าวเหนียวหมูปิ้งเนี่ยนะคะอย่าเดี๋ยว 2
หมูปิ้ง
8 ไม้โห
มาก
นี่เนาะนักเรียนอาจจะเคยเห็นนะคะเพราะว่า
อืมเข้าเหนียวหมูปิ้งเนาะเป็นอาหารเช้า
ของคนไทยถ่ายฮ่าๆๆคนไทยกินข้าวเหนียวเลย
หรอ
เพราะว่ามันอิ่มเชื่อมั้ยข้าวเหนียวเนี่ย
ข้าวเหนียวเนี่ยเวลากินกินกินหรือแบบ
อิ่มนานๆคะถ้าคนไทยกินกาแฟเป็น Witch
ไม่อิ่มแซนวิชไม่ได้เหรอทำไมอ่ะคนไทยกิน
ไม่อิ่มไงอ่ะ the  sandwich แซนด์วิชเป็น
อาหารเช้าของฝรั่งไหมอ่ะไม่รู้เนาะ
แซนด์วิชก็จะเป็นสามเหลี่ยมแบบนี้ใช่ไหม
คะมีอะไรคะแฟนเบสแซนด์วิชนี่มั้ย
อ๋อหน้าก็จะมีแฮงมีผักสวยเป็นแซนด์วิช
แล้วก็นักเรียนก็จะมีกาแฟ
เป็นกาแฟจะเป็นกาแฟร้อน
ด้วยกัน
แซนด์วิชกับกาแฟ
คนไทยบอกมั้ยอิ่มไม่อิ่มใช้แบนด์วิธแน่
กิน 1 ชั่วโมงหนึ่งชั่วโมง 2 ชั่วโมง
หมดแล้วหิวหิว
ซีริลก็ไม่อิ่มไม่อยู่
นั่นแหละอ่าใส่ serial เนี่ยเป็นอาหารสาว
ของนักเรียนในเวลานักเรียนตื่นนอนมาอาบ
น้ำแปลงฟันแล้วก็จะกินซีเรียลเป็นอาหาร
สาวแต่คนไทยเนี่ยไม่แบบไทยสมัยต้องเข้า
เหนียวหมูปิ้งข้าวเหนียวแล้วก็หมูวันนี้
เป็นหมู
หมูเนาะหมูหมูหมูหมู
หมูหมู
มามาทำมาจากหูเป็นข้าวเหนียวหมูปิ้งดี
เป็นอาหารสาวถ้านักเรียนอยู่
กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมหลังจากบ้านอพาทเม้นท์ไป
ออฟฟิศก็จะเห็นคนเดียวหมูปิ้งข้าวเหนียว
หมูปิ้งข้าวเหนียวหมูปิ้งมากๆถูกต้องมีมี
ข้าวเหนียวหมูปิ้งในมีเยอะนะฮะเพราะว่าคน
ไทยชอบกินนายแล้วก็ไม่แพง
ราคาถูกบางทีเนี่ยขายเป็น set ค่ะ 1  11
R  1 เซต 25 บาทน้อข้าวเหนียว 1 ห่อ
หมูปิ้ง 4 ไม้เนาะ
ประมาณนั้นถ้า 25 บาท 25 บาทแล้วก็ไม่แพง
กินแล้วอิ่มองค์อร่อยด้วยค่ะเมื่อหนู
อร่อยวันนี้
คนไทยก็เรียนมาประเทศไทยนะตอนเช้าอาหาร
สาวต้องกินน่ะเขาเหนียวหมูปิ้งถูกต้องค่ะ
นั่นแหละครูฝาก็เลยกินข้าวเหนียวหมูปิ้ง
บ่อยๆ
บ่อยๆมากินเป็นอาหารเช้าใช่ไหมคะกินเป็น
อาหารเช้าค่ะแล้วครูหญิงล่ะคะผู้หญิงกิน
อาหารเช้ากีบกินอาหารเช้าหรือยังครูหญิง
กินอาหารเช้าแล้วค่ะกินแล้ว
กินแล้ว
ผู้หญิงกินอาหารเช้ากี่โมงคะ
หนูกินอาหารเช้าตอน
เจ้าโมงครึ่งค่ะโอ้
9 โมงครึ่งน้องผู้หญิงกินอาหารสาว
9:30 น
ครูหญิงกินอาหารเช้ากินอะไรคะครูหญิงกิน
น้ำเต้าหู้ปาท่องโก๋
น้ำเต้าหู้ปาท่องโก๋ท
อย่าเพิ่งถ้านักเรียนมากรุงเทพฯและนัก
เรียนเดินที่กรุงเทพฯนักเรียนจะเห็น
หมูปิ้งสไลด์หมูปิ้งมากๆตอนเช้า 7 จะมี
อีกหนึ่งอย่างที่นักเรียนจะเห็นแล้วจะ
อยู่คู่กันก็คือ
น้ำเต้าหู้นะอันนี้นะ
อันนี้นะน้ำเต้าหู้นะคะแล้วก็
ปาท่องโก๋อาหา
มันคืออะไรอ่ะผู้หญิงน้ำเต้าหู้ปาท่องโก๋
เนี่ยน้ำเต้าหู้อันนี้คือน้ำเต้าหู้เนาะ
น้ำเต้าหู้นะคะก็ทำมาจากพี่ถั่วเหลือง
ถั่วเหลืองแล้วก็เปลี่ยนน้ำเต้าหู้มาส่วน
ปาท่องโก๋ไข่ Donut ค่ะ
นี่ค่ะปาท่องโก๋เป็นคาร์โบไฮเดรต
ก็เป็นแล้วก็เอาไปทอดจะแลกอะไร
เขาก็จะมี
มีกระทะ
สมัยมีกระทะแล้วก็มีไฟเราก็ใส่น้ำมันน้ำ
มัน
น้ำมันแล้วก็ใส่น้ำมันลงไปนะคะแล้วก็สนิท
แป้ง 1  2  2 ชิ้นคู่กันแล้วก็ลงไปที่นี่
น่าจะเป็นแป้งสาลีเนาะๆค่ะเป็นแป้งสาลี
แล้วก็เอาลงไปทอด
แล้วมันก็จะเปลี่ยนเป็นปลาท้องโอ้โห
her ปากเวลากินไว้กินปาท่องโก๋
ทูกับน้ำเต้าหู้
ติดตามช่องโก๋แล้วก็เอาน้ำเต้าหู้ใส่ออก
แบบนี้เอาปาท่องโก๋จิ้ม
อร่อยอร่อยกินปาท่องโก๋กับกาแฟได้ไหมคะ
ได้ค่ะครูฟ้านี่เห็นไหมปลาท่องโก๋แล้วก็
กาแฟ 9 แซแบบไทยยอมแพ้แบบไทยไม่ใช่กาแฟ
สตาร์บัคไม่ใช่ S เพรสโซ่อเมริกาโน่ลาเต้
ไม่ใช่เป็นกาแฟแบบไทยแล้วก็มีปาท่องโก๋
ไม่เหมือนกันกาแฟแบบไทยไม่เบื่อเหมือน
กาแฟแบบไทยไม่แพงถูกๆเด่นตรงอาจจะประมาณ
10 บาท
1 แก้ว
90บาทจ่ายค่ะ
อันนี้ก็เป็นอาหารเช้าของคนไทยอ่าๆน้องมี
มีข้าวเหนียวใช่ไหมข้าวเหนียวข้าวเหนียว
หมูปิ้งนะคะอ่ะน้ำเต้าหู้ปลาท่องโก๋กลาย
เป็นอาหารฟ้าวแล้วก็มีอีกอย่างนึงที่เป็น
อาหารเช้าของคนไทยที่คนไทยชอบกินตอนเช้า
อะไรคะครูหญิง
โสมค่ะนี่เราเรียกว่าโจ๊ก
นักเรียนงงไหมอะไร
ทำไมๆเลย
โจ๊กมีโจ๊กเนี่ยเป็นข้าวหนาอันนี้น่ะเป็น
ข้าวน้องเป็นข้าวที่ต้มนาน
ๆจนบันเละต้องมี
เละแบบมองเละ
คะ
แล้วก็ต้ม 100 องศาเซลเซียส
จ่ายหักต้องนานๆ
จนข้าวเนี่ยมันนิ่มๆมันนิ่มๆนิ่มๆแต่ก็
เวลากินอ่ะอ้าว
กลืนได้เลยสวยและกินโจ๊กเนี่ยมีมีช้อนตัด
โจ๊กไม่ต้องเคี้ยวโอเคเขียวนิดหน่อยสมัย
ก็จะเป็นอย่างในรูปนี้ก็เป็นโจ๊กแล้วก็
อันนี้เป็นหมูนะคะหมูเหมือนกันโจ๊กหมู
แล้วก็มีไข่
รักใคร
ตายแล้วจะเป็นอาหารสาวของคนไทยชายคนไทยก็
ชอบกินโจ๊กนะคะตอนเช้าอ้าว
นอกจากโจ๊กแล้วคนไทยก็ต้องกินอันนี้เป็น
ข้าวต้ม
ก็สวยเป็นข้าวเป็นข้าวที่ต้มข้าวต้มกับ
โจ๊กไม่เหมือนกันหรอคะไม่เหมือนกันใช่ไหม
โจ๊กเนี่ยข้าวเนี่ย
ต้มนานๆแต่เค้าต้ม
เค้าต้มเขาต้มเนี่ย
ข้าวยังเป็นเม็ดใช้เม็ดข้าวเม็ดข้าวเม็ด
ข้าวไปร้านตัดข้าวต้มเนี่ยต้องต้องเคี้ยว
ต้องเขียวก็เป็นข้าวต้มข้าวต้มหมู
เขาต้มเกาะคล้ายๆโจ๊ก
แต่ว่าโจ๊กจะกินง่ายกว่านะคะสายค่ะให้
กว่าเกิดสำหรับบางคนไม่ชอบโจ๊กไงไม่ชอบ
Texture
ก็กินข้าวต้มจ่ายกูก็จะทำให้จ๊อบกินข้าว
ต้มก็ข้าวเหนียวหมูปิ้ง
ข้าวเหนียวหมูปิ้ง
ข้าวไข่เจียวนอนนี้คือไข่เจียวข้าวไข่
เจียวก็เป็นอาหารเช้าของคนไทย
ทำเร็วๆกินเร็วๆเพราะว่าคนไทยอ่ะตอนเช้า
ต้องไปออฟฟิศใช่ไหมคะเออก็ต้องเร็วเร็ว
บางทีข้าวไข่เจียวทำง่าย
แล้วเราไข่เจียวเนี่ยใช้เวลานิดหน่อย
เสร็จแล้วใช่ไหมทำหน้าก็เร็วเวลากินก็กิน
เร็วๆเพราะว่าต้องรีบปิดออฟฟิศออฟฟิศ
ออฟฟิศออฟฟิศรีบไปออฟฟิศอาหารก็ก็
ข้าวไข่เจียวก็เป็นอาหารเช้าค่าของคนไทย
ต้องหาคนไทย in ข้าวไข่เจียวมากทวีมี
อาหารเช้าอีกหนึ่งอย่างที่คนไทยก็ชอบกิน
แต่ไม่รู้นักเรียนเคยเห็นไหมนะเนี่ยจะไม่
กินก็ได้นะอะไรอ่ะคืออะไรมากว่าต้มเลือด
หมูอันนี้เป็นซุปเนื้อหาเป็นซุปร้อนๆแล้ว
ก็มีหมูอันนี้เป็นเนื้อหมูหมูหมูหมูอู้ด
อู้ด
แต่ว่าสีน้ำตาลอันนี้นะคะสีน้ำตาลอันนี้
นะคือรืดหมู
เลือดหมู
เลือดนะคะแต่เป็นเลือดของหนึ่งหนี
เทอม
น้องหมูอ่ะ
แม่ไม่สบายคุณแล้วก็จริงๆ
ที่นี่นะคะเป็นเลือดของหู
ใต้ก็ทำเป็นแบบนี้ใช่ไหมอะไรค่ะเนี่ยค่ะ
เลือกหนูสมัยคุณก็เอามาหันหันหันแล้วก็
เป็นซุปต้มซุปแล้วเรียกว่าต้มเลือดหมูอัน
นี้เนี่ยนักเรียนอาจจะไม่กินเค้กส่วน
ไม่อาจจะเห็นแล้วก็ไม่เอามีแต่คนไทยกิน
มันร้อนๆอะไรบางครั้งนะเนี่ยจะเห็นแบบนี้
ไม่มีเลือดหมูมีหมูนะคะหมู
ก็มันอร่อยนะจริงๆเนาะกินคู่กับข้าวสมัย
มีข้าวแล้วก็มีต้มเลือดหมู
หรืออิ่มตอนเช้าเป็นอาหารเช้าถ้านักเรียน
ไม่อยากกินเลือดหมูนักเรียนบอกว่าเอาต้ม
เลือดหมูไม่ใส่เลือดหมูได้ไหม
ok นะพรุ่ง
เรียกหมูไม่ใส่เลือกหนูเออนั้นเองก็บอก
ว่าเอาต้มเลือดหมูแต่เลือดหมูเนี่ยไม่เอา
ไม่เอาเอาแค่หมูย่างหมูบ่หมู
อัด
พอแล้วล้มหนูสายลองดูนะเออลองดูจะเป็น
อาหารเช้าของคนไทยใช่ไหมคะ
ก็จะมีปลาท่องกับ
มีปาท่องโก๋
อะไรคะน้ำเต้าหู้ค่ะแล้วก็นี้ก็เป็นน้ำ
เต้าหู้ปาท่องโก๋
หรือว่า
กาแฟปาท่องโก๋
อันนี้ล่ะคะโจ๊กค่ะโจ๋
อันนี้ล่ะคะข้าวต้ม
[เพลง]
แต่ก็โอ้อันนี้ของโปรดครูฟ้า
เข้าเหนียวหมูปิ้งห่าง
ข้าวไข่เจียวค่ะแล้วก็สุดท้ายเนาะ
ต้มเลือดหมูหาทางหมดนะก็เป็น
ร้านอาหารเช้าสมัยที่คนไทยเนี่ยชอบกินมี
หนึ่งตอนเช้านะกินเสร็จไปออฟฟิศหรือว่า
ซื้อแล้วก็ถือไปกินใช่ไหมคะที่ออฟฟิศน้อง
อ่ะเร็วอร่อยด้วยจ่ายค่ะถ้านักเรียนเคย
เห็นหรือว่ากินอาหารเช้าอะไรของไทยอยู่รถ
ชอบอะไรก็คอมเม้นบอกเราได้หรอจะนะคะวัน
นี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกันใหม่
medio หน้า No  ka
สวัสดีค่ะอ่า